[Music]
hey everybody its charlie they're
filming Avengers for reshoots right now
we got our first look at one of the
scenes I'll do a breakdown of that but
we also got confirmation on Captain
America Chris Evans future in the
franchise because of all the Captain
Marvel stuff that they released
yesterday so we got to break it down it
confirms some pretty big theories that I
think that most of us have had so if
you're brand new to the channel there's
a new round of that spider-man ps4
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video I'll name a winner at the end
of this Hawkeye's back to he just posted
this picture with his buzz cut good to
be back so I'll explain what he's up to
because he's not filming the same scenes
as Captain America is filming biggest
thing first though the future of Chris
Evans inside the Marvel Cinematic
Universe they confirm that he will be
leaving the franchise Captain Marvel
will be the new cap of the Avengers and
whereas Captain America was kind of a
leader and a point man next to Iron Man
I mean serve slightly different
functions but they were both the team
leaders Captain Marvel will also serve
that same function with black panther
but really like even though that makes
you wonder about what happens to Ironman
in the skort of a separate theory this
interview only referenced Captain
America so that's why I'm just focusing
on his character so that effectively
confirms that he will be the sacrifice
at the end of the movie and are there a
lot of people that think that Ironman
might died too or he might preserve his
consciousness because even though he's
taking a back seat in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe nobody has said that
Robert Downey jr. is completely leaving
the franchise they'll still be Tony
Stark Stark Industries is still very big
during spider-man far from home it's a
key part of the plot but there's a
separate video that I'm planning on
doing for that because there's another
scene from that movie so I'll talk about
that because it involves a bunch of Iron
Man characters but if Captain America
wasn't at the top of your death
predictions list for Avengers 4 I would
shoot him straight to the top right now
there's been a lot of fan art about
people thinking of Awesome ways for him
to go out like he gets a scene with
Peggy Carter in the afterlife they
finally get that dance that they never
got because he went into the ice and
then she grew up and went on with her
life so the cat dies theory is now
probably the most valid
now as for how he dies whether that
involves the soul Jim forming the
Infinity Gauntlet again or an alternate
version of it because of all the jumping
around in time that's still wide open
for theory crafting so exactly how he
goes out is still open to speculation
but I think he's gonna get the hero's
death because he's one of those people
like they said during infinity war that
line of dialogue we don't trade lives he
doesn't trade other people's lives for
his own remember the scene from the
first Captain America film he threw
himself on the grenade without a
moment's hesitation without knowing that
it was a fake so he actually thought
that he was going to give his life for
all of his squad mates there so cut the
present day think of all the conflicts
we've been through and what its gonna
take to save the universe
if somebody's sacrificing their life is
gonna help them do that cap will be the
first person to give up his life to do
that the reason why people were making
soul gem theories are because the whole
idea between cap and Tony is that they
have to resolve their arc cap really
cares about Tony Tony really cares about
cap but they have all that drama between
them so they've resolved that during
Avengers 4 so that by the end I on man
recognizes how much he cares about him
in cap winds up being the sacrifice that
allows Tony to wield in Infinity
Gauntlet but remember that's just
speculation now we know cap goes we
don't know exactly how he goes so what's
happening on set right now is a much
more mundane reshoot that they're doing
with the original team cap from Civil
War it's sort of a reunion that they're
having
it's ant-man cap with no beard in Black
Widow at a diner with a mystery motion
capture person that I'll talk about in a
second but the casualness of the scene
and the way they're dressed implies that
this is happening sometime early in the
movie maybe when they're just
reconnecting an ant-man has to explain
the quantum realm to them but the fact
that cap is walking around in broad
daylight without trying to mask his
appearance makes it seem like Ross has
pardoned him in the wake of the snap or
maybe all those people in the government
were turned to ash so there's nobody to
come after him anymore
either way I think it's more plausible
that given that half of all life on
planet Earth is gone
they
pardon him and he can just go about his
life now the scene that Hawkeye is
filming is not with them he's off doing
other stuff but the stages where they
filmed this in Atlanta are vast so
there's a lot of different scenes being
shot all at the same time the thing
about the motion capture person though
is that that's either a brand-new
character that we've never met before
who's completely motion-capture or
they're a stand-in for a motion capture
character that they're just swapping
later because maybe the actor isn't
available but the thing is is that he
doesn't look that tall he's white and
usually when they use stand-in actors
through the same bill the same makeup so
if this guy is a stand-in for somebody
else it's got to be either Tom Holland
or Mark Ruffalo because they're both
about the same height and they both play
motion-capture characters the thing
about this though is that it's more
likely that it's Mark Ruffalo stand-in I
don't know why they would use a
different actor because Mark Ruffalo
does all his own motion capture he said
that they have some crazy new technology
that they're using during Avengers 4 so
we said the version of the hope that
we're going to see during it is
mind-blowing in the way that they
accomplish that so he just saying that
the technology that they use to turn
banner into the Hulk has gotten way more
sophisticated so this might just be part
of the process where banner goes to
professor Hulk where he's not like full
giant green Hulk he's more of like a
medium sized chatty intelligent Hulk
with the mind of banner in the body of
the Hulk if in the wake of infinity war
he resumed his relationship with Black
Widow and they work together that would
give him a reason to be at this team cap
reunion scene that they're having but it
is totally possible that it's just some
random alien this fully motion-capture
walking around you guys can let me know
though who do you think this is because
I don't recognize that actor but the
motion capture suit he's wearing is
exactly like the one that Tom Holland
wore during infinity war and almost
exactly like the one that Mark Ruffalo
used to wear when he was doing the big
size Hulk so just remember that there in
the middle of reshoots right now we
might get a look at some more stuff
that's happening behind the scenes but
it can be very misleading because
there's all this time travel and play
the quantum realm ant-man coming in and
then trying to figure out how to save
the universe there's even a scene with
Iron Man in Wakanda obviously he's gonna
have scenes with Sheree at some point so
a lot of people saw him sitting here in
Wakanda doing this interview for
infinity war and they're like hey wait a
minute they filmed Avenger
for back-to-back so he probably filmed
his Wakonda scenes while they were
filming infinity war Wakonda scenes so
that means that while this infinity war
stuff was happening behind the scenes
they were also doing Avengers for stuff
so even though Tony was on Titan during
infinity war Robert Downey jr. was also
shooting scenes in Wakanda so it's just
a funny easter egg like oh you know of
course he was gonna go to Wakanda but we
didn't realize that we were looking at
that the whole time they've been a lot
of you asking me about details from the
movie as far as I know there have been
no official ly no leaks as what you
would call it so I wouldn't worry too
much about spoilers most of this is all
still speculation based on the actual
scenes they're filming remember what
they did during the infinity war trailer
they can be very misleading with the way
they present some of this stuff so just
keep that in mind when you're Theory
crafting but there were some new
trailers that dropped there's new
spider-man into the spider-verse
spider-man far from home so a lot of
spider-man related things happening this
weekend congratulations forecaster
you're the latest giveaway winner please
email me on the about page of my youtube
channel so I can get your details click
here to watch the official daredevil
season 3 teaser trailer and click here
for that Captain Marvel teaser thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]